สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
วันนี้เรามาวันนี้วันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 9
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนสิงหาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูเรียมตอนนี้ 9
โมงครึ่งค่ะผู้หญิง
นะคะ
ในวีดีโอช่อง comprettent
ก็มีช่อง YouTube ของครูเรียมใช่แล้ว
ผู้หญิงก็มีช่องช่องยูทูปของครูหญิงใช่
ไหมแล้วก็ผู้หญิงกับผู้เรียน
หรือว่าช่อง comprettentible ไทยที่นัก
เรียนเห็นนะคะเราใช้วิธีการสอนภาษาไทย
เนี่ยเหมือนกัน
สมัยก็คือครูหญิงครูเรียมพูดภาษาไทย
นักเรียนเนี่ยฟังแล้วก็ดูใช่ไหมเราก็จะ
ไม่มีแบบซับไตเติ้ลไม่มีแปลภาษาอังกฤษ
ซึ่งจริงๆเวลาทำช่อง YouTube มาไม่รู้ว่า
ครูเรียมเคยเจอหรือเปล่านะคะแต่ว่าผู้
หญิงเนี่ยก็เคยเจอบ้างไม่ได้เยอะนะคะก็
คือ
นักเรียนเนี่ยบางคนก็อาจจะมา comment ใช่
ไหมบอกว่าขอแบบ
subtitle ภาษาไทยได้ไหมหรือว่า subtitle
ภาษาอังกฤษได้ไหมหรือว่าแบบขอเขียนคำ
ศัพท์ได้ไหมอะไรอย่างนี้ค่ะซึ่ง
ผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงคิดยังไงกับเรื่องนี้
ทำไมผู้หญิงไม่
เสียหรอกผู้หญิงมีซับไตเติ้ลนะ
ไม่ใช่ทุกวิดีโอแต่คุณหญิงจะบอกว่า
จะคุยจะไม่ใส่ซับไตเติ้ลเพราะว่า
มันไม่ใช่วิธีของเราไงวิธีเรียนภาษาไทย
แบบเราเนี่ยจะไม่ใส่ซับไตเติ้ลนักเรียนจะ
มาฟังแล้วก็อ่านซับไตเติ้ลภาษาไทยแล้ว
เข้าใจไม่ได้
นักเรียนต้องฟังแล้วก็ดูครูแล้วก็เข้าใจ
จุดยืนของครูหญิงเลยนะคะครูเรียมไม่ใส่
ซับไตเติ้ลเป็นจุดยืนของช่องของไทยแล้วก็
ช่องของคุณหญิงชื่ออะไรนะคะใช่คิดว่าช่อง
compreter
[เพลง]
แบบว่า
เราไม่ใส่ subtitle แบบ
ยืนที่แบบแข็งแกร่งมากอ่ะเขียดเลยบอกเลย
ว่าฉันไม่ใส่ subtitle นะแบบว้าวมีจุดยืน
ที่จะไม่ใส่ซับไตเติ้ล
เพราะว่าอะไรคะผู้หญิงทำไมผู้หญิงถึงมี
จุดยืนว่าไม่ใส่เพราะว่าแบบไม่อยากให้นัก
เรียนมาอ่าน
อยากให้นักเรียนเข้าใจจากการอ่านภาษาไทย
เหมือนถ้านักเรียนเข้าใจจากการอ่านภาษา
ไทย
นักเรียนนักเรียนจบไม่เข้าคือเวลาเรียน
ออกไปใช้ชีวิตข้างนอกอ่ะ
นักเรียนไม่ได้ไปคุยกับคนไทยแล้วมันมี
subtitle ภาษาไทยให้นักเรียนไง
นักเรียนต้องเข้าใจแบบจากคนไทยพูดจะหน้า
ตาท่าทางจากการฟังแล้วก็เดาว่าอ๋อคนไทย
หมายถึงอะไรหรือว่าคนนี้เขาพูดอะไรกับเรา
เพราะว่ามันแต่ถ้าเราใส่ซับไตเติ้ลอ่ะค่ะ
มันจะทำให้เหมือนถ้านักเรียนไม่เข้าใจว่า
เอ๊ะครูพูดอะไรนักเรียนก็นักเรียนบางคน
อ่านได้ใช่ไหมใช่
ค่ะก็อาจจะมาอ่านซับไตเติ้ลแล้วอ๋อเข้าใจ
มันจะไม่ช่วยให้นักเรียนเรียนแบบธรรมชาติ
อ่ะค่ะมันจะทำให้นักเรียนใช่ค่ะตอนแรก
เรียนก็ไม่ได้มีแบบเรียนไม่ได้มีเรียนพูด
ตรงๆนะเรียนไม่ได้มีจุดยืนเรื่องแบบใส่
ทรัพย์หรือไม่ใส่ซับอะไรแบบนี้เรียมก็แบบ
พอนักเรียนบอกว่าครูคะแบบขอแบบมีทรัพย์
ไตเติ้ลให้หน่อยนึงก็อ้าวโอเคค่ะ
เนมก็ไม่ได้รู้นะว่าแบบยังคิดว่าเออเขาคง
มีเหตุผลหรือว่ามีประโยชน์กับเขาอะไรบาง
อย่างนี่แหละเขาถึงแบบขอเรามาก็โอเคถ้า
เราแบบมีเวลาเดี๋ยวเราพิมพ์ให้อะไรประมาณ
เนี้ยแต่ว่าครูหญิงก็คือมีจุดยืนใช่ไหม
ใช่แต่ของผู้หญิงก็มี subtitle นะใน
วีดีโอที่เป็นออกไปข้างนอกอ่ะค่ะเพราะว่า
กลัวเสียงมันไม่ชัดแต่ว่าคือผู้หญิงจะมี
เหมือนคือ subtitles ภาษาไทยอ่ะมันมันก็
โอเคมันก็โอเคแหละค่ะมันยังแบบยังน้อยมัน
ก็ยังเป็นภาษาไทยอ่ะใช่อย่างน้อยแบบนัก
เรียนก็ยังได้อ่านภาษาไทยใช่ไหมคะแต่ว่า
ถ้าเป็นภาษาอังกฤษอะไรอย่างนี้อันนี้ไม่ๆ
ๆไม่ใส่หรือว่า
อยากใส่อันนี้
ไม่ได้แน่นอนเลยค่ะคือผู้หญิงก็มีจุดยืน
แต่ผู้หญิงก็ยังไม่ได้แบบอู้ขนาดแบบ
completible  7  cantony นะคะแบบเค้า
เขียนไว้เลยว่าเขาไม่ใส่ซับไตเติ้ลนะงั้น
แบบว่าค่อนข้างมีจุดยืนมากๆที่แบบฉันไม่
ใส่นะไม่ว่าคุณจะพูดอะไรคุณก็ไม่ใส่ไม่
ใส่ไม่ใส่อ๋อเวลาที่คนเรามีจุดยืนนะเขาก็
จะแบบไม่ยอมเปลี่ยนง่ายๆ
ก็จะแบบทำแบบนี้แหละจะแบบนี้แหละไม่ว่าจะ
ยังไงก็จะทำแบบนี้
เป็นผู้หญิงกับครูเรียมก็คือจุดยืนของเรา
ที่น่าจะเหมือนกันมากๆแล้วก็แบบไม่
เปลี่ยนแล้วก็แบบไม่ทำตามแน่นอนไม่ว่าจะ
มีนักเรียนแบบอาจจะ comment แต่ไม่เคยมี
นะคะแต่หมายถึงว่าจะมีนักเรียนมา comment
comment  comment  comment เยอะๆคิดว่า
ผู้หญิงกับผู้เรียนก็ไม่ทำก็คือไม่แปล
ภาษา
ภาษาอังกฤษ
ใช่ค่ะอันนี้ที่เราพูดถึงเป็นจุดยืนของ
ครูที่สอนภาษาไทยโดยเฉพาะในกรณีไทยครู
หญิงในช่อง understand  Thai เราก็เตรียม
ที่แบบจุดยืนเกี่ยวกับเรื่องการพูดภาษา
ไทยอย่างเดียวแต่ว่าสำหรับบางคนที่เขามี
จุดยืนในเรื่องอื่นอย่างเช่นการแบบดูแล
สิ่งแวดล้อม
[เพลง]
รักลูกอย่างนี้หรอคะรักลูกใช่เขาก็จะมี
วิธีการทำของเขาเพื่อที่จะแสดงจุดยืนของ
เขาออกมา
เหมือนเด็กผู้หญิง 1 คนใช่ไหมคะเด็กผู้
หญิงสวีเดนน่ะเกรต้าใช่ไหมหญิงจำไม่ได้
ว่าน้องชื่ออะไรอ่ะนี่แหละลืมจำได้แต่
เกรย์ๆอะไรสักอย่างนั่นแหละ
ขอโทษนะคะต้องพูดผิดจำไม่ได้จริงๆแต่นึก
หน้าออกอยู่นะใช่ใครนึกออกก็แบบช่วยบอก
เราทีนะเป็นผู้หญิงเป็นเด็กผู้หญิงนะที่
ออกมาพูดเกี่ยวกับภาวะโรคร้อนโรคร้อน
เนี่ยทุกคนต้องช่วยกันนะคือแบบหยุดใช้
พลาสติก
แบบนี้แล้วก็ทำอะไรบ้างอ่ะผู้หญิงถ้าเกิด
คนที่เขามีจุดยืนเรื่องสิ่งแวดล้อมอ่ะเขา
ก็จะออกมาพูดใช่ไหมบอกว่าตอนนี้พวกคุณทำ
ร้ายโลกอยู่ต้องอยู่ตอนนี้นะมันร้อนมาก
ใช่ไหมเราต้องดูแลนะเพราะว่าเราอยู่ไม่
ได้แล้วเราถ้าเราแต่งงานเรามีลูกลูกเราก็
อยู่ไม่ได้เขาก็จะพยายามให้ทุกคนรู้ว่า
เฮ้ยตอนนี้โลกของเรามันร้อนมากๆแล้วเขาก็
จะพยายามพูดแบบอาจจะมีทำเป็นเหมือนคล้ายๆ
โบรชัวร์ไหมใบปลิวแล้วก็แบบแจกแล้วก็ถ้า
มีเวลาก็จะไปพูดพูดเหมือนน้องเด็กผู้หญิง
สวีเดนนั้นชื่อเกรย์ต้าหรือ greator เขา
ก็จะแบบเวลาเราคิดถึงเขาเราจะบอกว่าคนนี้
เขามีจุดยืนเกี่ยวกับสิ่งแวดล้อมอ่ะมากๆ
ใช่ๆแล้วไม่ใช่แค่เด็กผู้หญิงคนนี้นะก็
เห็นหลายๆคนนะที่แบบเวลาที่ออกไปข้างนอก
บ้านก็จะแบบไม่ซื้อน้ำเป็นขวดอ่ะก็เอาเขา
เรียกว่าอะไรนะกระบอกน้ำของตัวเองอ่ะ
แหละใช้กระบอกน้ำไม่แบบใช้ขวดพลาสติกเยอะ
ๆหรือว่าเวลาไปซุปเปอร์มาเก็ตไปตลาดก็จะ
เอาแบบตะกร้าเอาถุงไปด้วยแล้วก็บอกแม่ค้า
บอกว่าไม่เอาถุงพลาสติกค่ะไม่ต้องใส่ถุง
ค่ะ
เขาก็มีจุดยืนของเขา
ผู้หญิงก็เคยเป็นนะคนเดียว
แต่ว่าไม่ได้แบบสุดไม่ได้ขนาดนั้นแต่ว่า
ผู้หญิงก็มีแบบเหมือนกันว่าตอนเมื่อก่อน
ก่อนช่วงโควิดเวลาผู้หญิงไปข้างนอกก็จะมี
กล่องใส่ข้าวไปด้วยมีช้อนที่เป็นช้อนไม่
ใช่ไม่เอาช้อนพลาสติกแล้วก็แบบผู้หญิงจะ
ค่อนข้างมีจุดยืนมากๆเกี่ยวกับหลอด
พลาสติกว่า
จะพยายามไม่ใช้ไม่อยากใช้หลอดพลาสติกเยอะ
ๆเพราะว่าเวลาเราดื่มน้ำใช่ไหมมันจะมี
หลอดอ่ะค่ะเป็นอย่างแรกเลยอ่ะที่ผู้หญิง
ซื้อแล้วก็พกใส่กระเป๋าไปด้วยเพราะว่า
หลอดเขาเรียกอะไรนะ
เพราะว่าเราเหมือนเราเคยเคยฟังพี่หนึ่งคน
น่ะเขาเล่าให้ฟังว่าเวลาเราใช้หลอด
พลาสติกอ่ะ
แล้วเราทิ้งแล้วมันไปที่ทะเลแล้วเต่าอ่ะ
ค่ะเต่ามันกินหลอดพลาสติกเข้าไปอ่ะแล้วทำ
ให้เต่ามันตายเลยหรือเปล่าไม่แน่ใจบางคน
ก็ไม่สบายแล้วก็มีหนอนในท้อง
นั่นแหละแต่ว่าผู้หญิงจะค่อนข้างแบบตอน
นั้นคือแบบโอ้ไม่ๆๆๆฉันจะไม่ใช่พลาสติก
คุณจะไม่ใช้หลอดพลาสติก
เจาะพยายามมากๆที่จะไม่ใช้หลอดพลาสติกก็
ถือว่าเป็นจุดยืนอยู่ช่วงหนึ่งนะ
คะเหมือนช่วงก่อนหน้านี้เหมือนกันค่ะคุณ
หญิงที่แบบมีจุดยืนด้านสิ่งแวดล้อมก็คือ
รถใช้พลาสติก
แต่พอแบบมีโควิดเข้ามาบางทีเราก็ลืมไปเลย
เพราะว่าแบบ
เราก็หาทางป้องกันตัวเองเนาะ
เวลาไม่ว่าจะไปซื้อน้ำที่ไหนก็จะให้แก้ว
ให้แก้วเขาอ่ะไม่ใช้พยายามจะไม่อยากใช้
พลาสติกให้มันเยอะเหมือนรถใช่ไหมก็ถือว่า
เป็นจุดยืนนะของเราแต่อาจจะไม่ได้มากขนาด
นั้นเพราะว่าแบบช่วงโควิดที่เราเปลี่ยนไป
นิดนึงเพราะว่าบางร้านหลายๆร้านเขาก็ไม่
รับเอาแก้วของเราเนี่ย
ไม่รับแก้วที่แบบลูกค้าเอามาด้วยนะคะก็
คือแบบต้องซื้อแล้วที่ร้านทำให้แล้วก็เอา
ออกไปเลย
ใช่เพราะว่ามันตอนนั้นเนาะตอนช่วงโควิด
เพราะว่าใช่ค่ะมันเหมือนกับว่ามีคนที่อาจ
จะมีชื่อเสียงอ่ะแบบดารานักร้องอย่าง
เงี้ยก็หลายๆคนที่เขาก็จะมีจุดยืนเรื่อง
เรื่องสิ่งแวดล้อมแบบนี้ค่ะเขาก็จะใช้พวก
กล่องพลาสติกกล่องข้าวแก้วน้ำก็จะพกไป
ด้วยอย่างนี้มีถุงผ้าเขาจะไม่ใช้ถุงอะไร
ที่เป็นพลาสติกเลยใช่ไหมบางทีเราเห็นเรา
เห็นจุดยืนของเขาแล้วเราก็รู้สึกว่าเออ
มันก็ดีนะแล้วมันก็ไม่ได้ยากแต่แค่พก
กระเป๋าแล้วก็ใส่ของก็ทำให้เราอยากทำตาม
ใช่ๆเรานอกจากเรื่องแบบที่ครูครูสอนภาษา
ไทยมีจุดยืนเรื่องการพูดภาษาไทยในการสอน
เท่านั้นแล้วก็จุดยืนด้านสิ่งแวดล้อมที่
คนแบบอยากรักสิ่งแวดล้อมอยากดูแลสิ่งแวด
ล้อมเค้าก็จะแบบต่อต้านพวกพลาสติกแล้วยัง
คิดว่าหลายๆคนก็มีจุดยืนของตัวเองนะ
บางคนก็มีจุดยืนเกี่ยวกับแบบความดีแบบนี้
ใช่ๆต้องทำดี
ใช่ใครที่ทำไม่ดีเนี่ยนะไม่ได้ไม่ได้ไม่
ได้
ถ้าผู้หญิงมีจุดยืนเรื่องความดีมากๆอ่ะ
มันก็จะแบบเกรียมทำไมคุณลืมทำแบบนี้มัน
ไม่ดีนะ
ถ้ามีจุดยืนแล้วก็เป็นที่ตัวเองโอเคนะแต่
มันมีจุดยืนแล้วก็ไปว่าคนอื่นอันนี้ก็ไม่
ค่อยโอเคนะแต่บางครั้งเราก็เห็นเหมือนกัน
เนาะ
ใช่แต่บางทีแบบถ้าเกิดเขามีจุดยืนตรงนั้น
แล้วเขาขับทำตัวเองแบบเป็นคนดีมันก็โอเค
แต่บางทีนะก็จะแบบเหมือนออกแบบทางไปตัด
สินคนอื่นน่ะเวลาคนที่ทำไม่ดีหรือว่าไม่
ได้ทำเหมือนที่เขาทำอ่ะเขาก็จะมองว่าแบบ
ไม่ดีนะทำไมทำแบบนี้ผู้หญิงมีจุดยืน
เรื่องไม่ใช้พลาสติกแล้วเห็นครูเรียมใช้
พลาสติกเหมือนเงินมีพลาสติกอย่างเงี้ยค่ะ
ผู้หญิงก็แบบเรียน
ไม่รักสิ่งแวดล้อมเหรอคะทำไมครูเรียมถึง
ใช้พลาสติก
ทำไมไม่ได้นะคะคือผู้หญิงรู้สึกว่าแบบเรา
ไม่ว่าเราจะมีจุดยืนเรื่องอะไรอ่ะเราทำ
แค่ตัวเราเนาะคนอื่นเนี่ยเราไม่ได้บอกเขา
ดีกว่าไหมใช่หรือว่าบางคนเขามีจุดยืนไม่
เหมือนเราไงบางคนก็ฉันจะกินทุกอย่างที่
ฉันอยากกินฉันมีจุดยืนที่ชัดเจนฉันเกิดมา
ครั้งหนึ่งเนี่ยฉันจะกินอะไรก็ได้มันคือ
จุดยืนของฉันอย่ามาห้ามฉันอย่ามาบอกฉันคน
อื่นจะมีจุดยืนเรื่องรถน้ำหนักหรือว่า
ร่างกายแข็งแรงแต่มันไม่ใช่จุดยืนของฉัน
จุดยืนของฉันคือจิต
เออใช่แต่เรื่องกินเนี่ยผู้หญิงก็คิดได้
เหมือนกันนะทุเรียนพูดเร็วไปหรือเปล่าคะ
นักเรียนเอ่อ
บางคนที่เขาจะมีเขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะไม่กิน
เนื้อสัตว์อย่างนี้แบบ
[เพลง]
ใช่ถือว่าเป็นจุดยืนถ้าเกิดเรามีความตั้ง
ใจนะมันไม่ใช่เกี่ยวกับว่าใครมาบอกว่า
ต้องทำต้องทำอย่างนี้ไม่ใช่นะอยู่ที่แบบ
ตัวเราเองอ่ะที่แบบโอเคฉันมีจุดยืนว่าฉัน
จะเลิกกินเนื้อสัตว์แล้วฉันจะแบบวีแกน
อย่างเดียวมีคนไทยที่ทำแบบนี้นะมีจุดยืน
ที่แบบไม่กินเนื้อสัตว์แล้ว
แปลว่าแบบเรื่องกินมันก็ถือว่าเป็นจุดยืน
ได้คืออย่างผู้หญิงอ่ะมี
อันนี้ไม่รู้ว่าเป็นจุดยืนหรือเปล่านะก็
คือเหมือนน้องชายอ่ะค่ะน้องชายเนี่ยเขามี
แฟนแล้วน้องชายเนี่ย
แล้วคือแฟนน่ะเขาก็บอกกับน้องชายว่าถ้า
พี่เหมือนแบบเลิกบุหรี่ได้ไหมเออไม่สูบ
บุหรี่ได้ไหมอย่างนี้ค่ะเราแบบน้องเค้า
บอกโอเคอ้าวไม่เลิกจะเลิกแล้วทีนี้ 1 วัน
เนี่ยเขาก็เห็นว่าอ้าวน้องชายผู้หญิงหรือ
แฟนเขาอ่ะค่ะไม่เลิกสูบบุหรี่เหมือนที่
พูดเพราะเขาบอกว่าคือเขาโอเคทุกอย่างอะไร
เขาก็ไม่เป็นไรแบบเออเป็นแฟนกันเนาะรัก
กันโอเคคุยได้แต่บุหรี่เนี่ยไม่ได้เลย
100% พอเขาเห็นแบบแฟนเขาสูบบุหรี่เขาก็
เลยแบบโอเคไม่ได้อ่ะเลิกเลิกดีกว่าใช่
เพราะว่าผู้หญิงก็รู้สึกว่าเออ
แฟนของแฟนเก่านะคะของน้องเนี่ยเขาน่าจะมี
จุดยืนเรื่องแบบว่าเรื่องไม่รู้นะว่าใช้
จุดยืนหรือเปล่าแต่แบบเขาค่อนข้าง
ซีเรียสนะคะแบบว่า
อะไรก็ได้นะแต่บุหรี่เนี่ยบอกแล้วใช่ไหม
ว่าจะไม่สูบเพราะว่าเขาไม่โอเคพอได้กลิ่น
บุหรี่น่ะมันไม่โอเค
ถึงแม้รักแค่ไหน
เขายังคิดว่าเขาคงตั้งใจตั้งแต่แรกแล้ว
แหละว่าไม่อยากมีแฟนที่สูบบุหรี่
มันคือความตั้งใจนั่นแหละความเขาเรียกว่า
อะไรจุดยืนก็คือความตั้งใจที่จะไม่
เปลี่ยนถ้าเกิดสูบบุหรี่ก็ไม่เอาไงก็ไปหา
คนอื่นที่ไม่สูบแค่นั้นเอง
คุยกันแล้วด้วยอะไรอย่างนี้ว่าไม่เอา
บุหรี่นะ
ใช่เหมือนที่แบบเรา
หาแฟนใช่ไหมมันก็น่าจะเป็นจุดยืนได้ไหม
ว่าแบบฉันจะไม่แต่งงาน
ฉันจะอยู่คนเดียวฉันจะไม่มีลูก
ใช่อันนั้นก็คือจุดยืนแล้วก็ไม่เปลี่ยน
แล้วนะถ้าเกิดไม่เปลี่ยนคือจุดยืนแต่
สำหรับบางคนก็แบบฉันก็มีจุดยืนนะฉันต้อง
หาแบบสามีหรือว่าภรรยาชาวต่างชาติเท่า
นั้น
จุดยืนชัดเจนแล้วก็แบบบางคนนะผู้หญิงบาง
คนก็แบบผู้ชายไทยฉันจะไม่สนใจฉันมีจุดยืน
ที่ชัดเจนเพราะว่าฉันอยากได้สามีชาวต่าง
ชาติ
มีชัดเจน
ไม่เหมือนกันเนาะเขาก็แบบตั้งใจว่าแบบผู้
ชายไทยดีแค่ไหนหล่อแค่ไหนมัน
จะไม่เปลี่ยนใจ
หรือว่าต่างชาติเข้ามาแบบแฟนต้องเป็น
เอเชียเท่านั้น
เพราะมีจุดยืนชัดเจนฉันมีจุดยืนชัดเจนมาก
ประเทศแถวนี้หรือว่าอาจกำหนดเลยก็ได้นะ
ว่าต้องเป็นคนลาวเท่านั้นต้องเวียดนาม
เท่านั้นแฟนต้องเป็นคนไทยเท่านั้นจุดยืน
ชัดเจน
ฉันต้องแบบนี้ไม่เปลี่ยนใช่
จุดยืนหรอตรงนี้ไง
เกี่ยวกับภาษาไทยนี่แหละที่แบบจะไม่สอน
แบบแปลในแบบเขาเรียกว่าอะไรนะ cover ของ
YouTube ของ Facebook เหลี่ยมก็เลยเขียน
เลยนะเมื่อก่อนบอกว่า
แบบไม่ให้แปลอ่ะแต่ว่าแบบให้เริ่มคิดให้
เริ่มคิดเป็นภาษาไทย
แปลได้ไหมครูสอนแบบนี้ได้ไหมอย่างนี้
เหมือนเมื่อก่อนเราทำงานที่โรงเรียนไงก็
จะมีนักเรียนที่เข้ามาบอกว่าเออทำแบบนี้
ด้วยสิไม่เอาแบบไม่เอาแบบฟัง 100% ไม่เอา
แบบ compreter  input  100% เนี่ยไม่เอา
หรือว่า a  LG เนี่ยไม่เอาเปลี่ยนได้ไหม
ซึ่งเมื่อก่อนโรงเรียนที่ครูหญิงสอนเนี่ย
ภาษาไทยเนี่ยนะคะเขาก็มีจุดยืนว่าใหม่เรา
สามารถแบบนี้แหละ
แค่นั้นก็จบไม่เปลี่ยน
ทำแบบนี้ทำ 2 อย่างสิเราบอกไม่เปลี่ยน
วิธีของเรามันโอเคนักเรียนเราเก่งหลายคน
มากๆไงได้นักเรียนเก่งหลายคนแต่ว่าถ้า
เกิดอยากได้แบบแบบนั้นนะครูคนอื่นก็มีไง
เราก็ไม่ได้ห้ามใช่ไหมโรงเรียนอื่นก็เยอะ
เราก็บอกเลยแบบเออเนี่ยมีโรงเรียนอื่นนะ
คะที่เขาสอนแบบนี้แบบเยอะมากๆสมัยนั้นเลย
ก็บอกว่าก็ชอบแบบ alga ชอบครูแบบ alg
สนุกแต่อยากได้ภาษาไทยภาษาอังกฤษด้วยแล้ว
ก็แบบ
ชัดเจนมากชัดเจนของเราสองคนนะคะเพราะว่า
เราไม่แปลเป็นภาษาอังกฤษเพราะว่าเราภาษา
อังกฤษไม่โอเคนะคะใช่เพราะเราพูดภาษา
อังกฤษไม่ได้เลย
[เพลง]
ค่ะเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอนะคะใช่
แล้วค่ะวันนี้ลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะครูหญิงลาไป
ก่อนแล้วค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ